hello everyone and welcome to the last
day before the world chess championship
match in dubai starts uh we're going to
have magnus crossing the reigning world
champion defending his title against the
challenger yanni ponichi of russia and
today i decided to show you not one but
two games and these are the only two
games magnus ever lost in a world chess
championship match so we're gonna show
uh the one uh from 2014 match against
anand and the one uh from the london
from the new york match against sergey
karjakin uh in 2016. uh so as you know
uh this will be carlson's fifth world
champ championship match he played four
of them uh the first one against anand
in 2013 when where he won his world
chess championship title he won three
games and lost the zero game so that was
a very clean uh victory and then ananda
challenged him back in 2014 they played
in sochi in russia magnus again won
three games but anand was able to win
one game and it was a pretty pretty
impressive one this is the one that
we're going to show then we're going to
show the one against uh sergey karjakin
that was played in in london in uh sorry
in new york in 2016 uh it was a game
eight of the match first seven games
were drawn then uh karjakin won the
eighth game and then magnus was
successful in retaliating in game 10
then the classical portion of the match
ended in a draw and then of course
magnus defeated karjakin in the rapid
tie breaks and then of course there was
the match against fabi in london where
all 12 games ended in a draw and then
magnus again
won the rapid tie breaks and now we have
the 2021 match in dubai against nipple
where we will not be having 12 games
we'll have it we'll be having 14
classical games which means there's a
well a bit of a bigger chance that the
the classical world chess championship
is actually decided in classical time
format and not in rapid tie breaks but
still uh you know i i wouldn't count on
it it's possible nepo style is a bit
different he is you know playing a lot
faster he is choosing riskier lines so
we could be seeing you know a win here
and there but uh you know it's still
it's still hard to you know dig up a win
in classical time format so we'll see
what happens and will this uh be yet
another uh world championship match
decided in rapid time time time format
or you know god forbid armageddon or
will it actually end in uh in classical
time format uh that's you know that's
what we'll be enjoying for for the next
three weeks but now let's check out what
it takes to beat magnus carlsen in a
wheelchair championship match the first
game we're going to show is anand versus
carlson this is a game three of their uh
world champion championship match in
sochi russia yeah so let's see how the
game went uh so the the match started by
uh first game being a draw then magnus
won the second game and then anand
retaliated in game three so let's see
how he did it uh
anand started with d4 we have knight to
f6 by magnus c for e6 knight to f3 and
d5 so a normal queen's gambit declined
knights to c3 bishop to e7 and now
bishop to f4 going for the harvest
attack uh not the standard bishop to g5
but uh a bit a bit of a sharper idea of
bishop to f4 and it seems like uh
knights to b5 is a very scary threat but
i'm just quickly going to show if anyone
plays this against you you can you can
safely castle here it doesn't matter if
he goes knight b5 uh you just invite him
to go knight c7 just c6 knight c7 and
now bishop to be for check and you win
there's really no good way to defend
this uh you can block with the queen or
you lose your queen if you move the
bishop you lose the knight on c7 and if
you move the knight then e5 here you
block the bishop so now you're ready to
capture the knight and if bishop
captures then knight e4 the bishop no
longer defends the knight so now you're
threatening bishop captures on d2 and if
the bishop goes back queen f6 now
attacking the bishop if the bishop moves
you're gonna checkmate the white king so
here uh everything completely just falls
apart for example g3 you can even just
capture bishop captures on the two
bishop captures and queen captures and
f2 checkmate
just in case uh someone plays this
against you but okay uh here of course
anand continued with e3 we have knight
beat to d7 and now
continuing with c5 and in the olden days
if you played something like this they
would say you know you are completely
mad uh i i think even stein it said
something like this at one point that
this is completely anti-positional and
it's uh you know no way to play with
white you can easily undermine uh this
expansion white created with wood moves
like b6 if b4 then a5 and it's just not
good but here anand plays it and there's
a very good reason he plays it so uh
carlson continues uh
with uh you know how everyone would uh
we have c6 uh bishop to d3 and now we
have b6 challenging that advanced c5
pawn we have b4 on and defends it and
now a5 continuing to undermine the
structure we have a3 and now bishop to
a6 attacking the bishop on d3
and this is the idea of this line bishop
captures an a6 rook captures in b5 anand
sacrifices a pawn
but for a very good reason he's going to
create a past c pawn so crossing
captures and we have c6 now
the knight is attacked but there's no
good way to move the knight so we're
just going to play queen to c8 this is
black's absolute best response of course
carlson knows this uh now if you capture
then queen captures and c3 comes with
the trick so ana advances his pawn all
the way to c7 it's only move 14 on and
already has a pawn and c7 so you know
very very good stuff here and now uh
here magnus plays b4 nowadays i i think
it's known that bishop captures an a3 is
kind of the best move because you know
if rook captures b4 can be played uh so
we're going to play knight captures on
b5 and then if bishop back to b for
czech king the f1 then like the e4 sort
of a
a line that would be preferable for for
black but okay b4 is also fine this is
what magnus played we have knight to b5
and now comes a4 interestingly this
position was reached in the 2002 feeding
grand prix against anakole karpov and
kirill giorgiov where knight to e4 was
played karpov was able to win this game
with the white pieces but here magnus
goes a4 now with some uh very nasty
threats of just creating a pass pawn of
course with b3 but also freeing up that
a5 square to capture uh the knight on b5
because the knight really doesn't have
any any good retreating squares so here
rook to see one by on and knight to e
for now uh putting more pressure on
white's position and now anand throws in
the the tricky move and that is knight
to g5 sort of offering a piece here uh
but the the knight can't be captured if
you capture the knight and then we're
gonna play bishop captures and if knight
captures uh and if knight captures on g5
uh you will play knight to d6 attack the
queen and now after the well you have to
give up the queen here there's no other
other move here if you move the queen we
just bring another queen into the game
and after rook captures you're going to
capture the rook with check and now the
queen again falls so really nothing
better to do here
so of course after night the g5 magnus
just went to knight d to f6 he improved
his position a little bit and now anand
trades once we have knight captures
knight captures and f3 now challenges
carlson's knight here on e4 uh and here
uh on uh uh carlson just goes rook to a5
he attacks the knight on b5 rather than
just trying to you know uh save his
knight on e4 also very interesting was
queen to d7 uh same idea we attacked the
knight here and now after f captures
we're gonna now of course you can't
capture right away because uh c8 queen
you have to play rook to c8 first and
now there's no good way to
defend this knight uh if you play queen
to d3 to defend it just rook a5 and the
knight will still fall so this would be
good for black but okay magnus went for
the immediate rook to a5 and now
we have f captures on e4 by anand and it
is now only as of move 20 that this
position has never been reached again
uh so let's see how magnus continues
rook captures on b5 you have to
recollect your piece and now comes queen
captures on a4 attacking carlson's rook
rook to a5 and now we have queen to c6
so
this is uh
this pass pawn is already very far
advanced but magnus also creates his own
pass pawn he plays b captures on a3 and
now he also has some a2a1 ideas you know
floating around uh anand plays e
captures on d5 and now we have rook
captures on d5
grabbing that pawn
we have queen captures on b6 and now
queen to d7 so carlson has to keep an
eye on that c8 square but he also needs
to keep an eye on his a3 pawn for the
moment anand cannot threaten this pawn
so he castles here uh and now comes rook
to c8 so now you don't have to worry
about um uh white advancing this pawn
and magnus is ready to play bishop to d6
the to cut off this bishop's defense of
the pawn and then maybe later on we can
worry about picking up this pawn so
anand plays rook to c6 he doesn't allow
magnus to play bishop to d6 and now uh
what do you play here it's it's a very
difficult position for black white has
all the pressure here in this position
and probably you should play something
like h6 and after rook after c1 white
will bring more pressure here you you
could play bishop to f6 and maybe the
game continues where white will always
be better but black should be able to to
survive because as soon as white
introduces something white has to give
up control of something then maybe black
can you know
grab onto that
and you know there are even some nice
tricks in the position for example if
something like h3 is played you can even
play some like rook captures on d4 so
white white has to be careful for
example captures captures uh you can
lose the queen here now it's of course
uh
not a very serious threat but there are
threats in the position but in the game
magnus played the g5 and this makes him
makes his position a little bit more
difficult to play uh anand brought the
bishop back bishop to g3 now comes
bishop to b4 uh offering a bishop for
the rook on c6 of course that's not
going to happen but what magnus is
really going for is bishop to a5 to win
that c7 pawn so here anan goes rook to
a1
and now what do you play here well it's
a it's a really difficult position to
evaluate and there really uh isn't a
move that's you know
particularly attractive for black you
know the engine is giving g4 as sort of
a way to continue playing this but it's
not uh it's not uh a move that's all
that impressive uh but in the game we
have bishop to a5 by magnus attacking
the queen going after that c7 pawn but
anan just plays queen to a6 and now what
do you play here uh well there are a lot
of
a lot of cool ideas in the position for
example e4 and well if this rook ever
moves away from the fifth rank then the
bishop just falls uh if you play
something like uh bishop
to b4 to get the bishop out of harm's
way then rook to b6 is enough for for a
win for white you're attacking the
bishop also rook this b8 will be a
terrible threat so magnus continued with
his plan he played bishop captures on c7
but now queen back to c4 and now you
can't move the bishop because rook
captures and c8 will just win and your
bishop is attacked three times so here
we have e5 uh magnus now blocks the
bishop's diagonal bishop captures on e5
and now rook captures on e5 he had to
give up the exchange to survive a little
bit longer but now after d captures on
e5 uh we have queen to e7 by magnus and
now on and plays e6
uh saying that you can't really capture
this um uh so so what are you gonna
what are you gonna play here uh magnus
played king to f8 he doesn't want his
king on this diagonal and now comes rook
to c1 and it was in this position on
move 34 that magnus carlsen uh resigned
the game as there is nothing more to it
to be done here so the bishop
cannot move or
if you don't move it the bishop will be
captured uh there's nothing for for
black to play here and it's just uh you
know a total annihilation here so it was
not an easy position to play and
interestingly uh black never really put
all that much counter play here
white really got a wonderful position
and then he converted it very
convincingly so
as you've seen it was uh like the
position was reached in 2002 by anatoly
karpov so you know uh even even in 2024
14 it still uh you know had some poison
to it so that was the one game magnus
lost uh now let's check out the other
one the other one is uh in the 2016 new
york match against sergey karjakin uh
let me just uh shift this now where
magnus had the white pieces and also a
very very interesting one uh let's see
what happened in this one so magnus
opened with d4 uh we have knight to f6
knight to f3 and d5 we have e3 and now
e6 the coal system
bishop to d3 and now karjakin strikes in
the center with c5 we have b3 by magnus
preferring to fianchetto his dark square
bishop and bishop to e7 both players
castle here and now bishop to b2 so this
is all been played before nothing new
here uh we have b6 by karjakin uh and
now the the position is is a known one
knight the b knight b to d2 and c4 are
very well known moves here but the move
magnus played is not a known move and it
was uh played then for the very first
time but it was also never played again
after it was played in this game so
magnus played d captures on c5 and it is
now a completely new game already as of
move eight
so uh one would expect that black would
capture with the b pawn sort of to
improve his presence in the center but
qarakan captures with the bishop and now
the bishop gains more activity and
well this is how he prefers to play it
and okay knight b to d2 by magnus with
bishop to b7 queen to e2 developing the
queen now connecting the rooks and
knight b to d7 karjakin also needs to do
the same if he wants to get his rooks
into the game we have c4 by magnus and
now uh karjakin captures on c4 d
captures on c4 knight captures on c4 and
queen to e7 also getting ready to bring
the rooks into the game so we have a3 uh
hoping to get that b4 move in as one
always should uh and of course uh
karjakin stops this with a5 we have
knight to b4 now
and rook to d8 uh so of course we have
to activate our rooks now rook after d1
rook a to c8 and now rook a to c1 and
both sides have sort of completed their
development uh kraken starts with knight
to f8 now the rook gains nice control of
the d-file and the knight is being
shifted over to g6 we have queen to e1
uh now preparing to bring the bishop
back to f1 so white can also gain some
control over the e file with the rook
knight to g6 and bishop to f1 so both
players just putting their pieces on
optimal squares and this bishop on f1
although it seems a little bit passive
it's it's actually quite active doing
good work here and also regarding that
g2 pawn against this monster bishop on
b7 so here karakin starts with knight to
g4 as not a lot of pieces here defending
carlson's king side you you might
consider some ideas like queen to h4 uh
nothing so barbaric but you know if
white allows it we're going to play it
of course
and here you could play something like
h3 just say go back and then we're going
to place the knight on e5 maybe see a
trade here and then kara can basically
just improve the position of his knights
but here we have knight to b5 by magnus
yeah so offering a trade of rooks along
the d file and the knight here on b6 on
b5 can be quite annoying as white has
quite a lot of control over that d6
square but for the moment black also
keeps control of the d6 square
so here we have bishop to c6 interesting
move is queen to g5 but it's very hard
to to make something out of this with
that that bishop on f1 being such a good
defender so here one example why bishop
to f1 is so impressive
uh so after knight to b5 we have bishop
to c6 now putting pressure on the knight
on b5 and magnus defends it with a4 we
have bishop to d5 now uh and bishop to
d4 now offering a trade of dark square
bishops we have bishop captures and c
for rook captures in c4 and now even
bishop captures on d4 so uh grabbing
that piece we have rook d captures on d4
now preparing to capture the knight on
g4 and now rook captures on c4 we have b
captures on c4 and the knight to f6 uh
so what do you play here well it's a
it's a very interesting position but you
can't really claim that white got
something out of the opening uh
there's really not all that much to uh
to do here the knight on b5 is somewhat
impressing but black's presence on the
king side is also very very nice so here
we have queen to d2 threatening to pick
up the rook here and uh karjakin just
brings the rook back to b8
we have g3 by magnus preparing to now
fianchetto the light square bishop and
grab hold of this diagonal and now
knight to e5 the f3 square was weakened
so of course why not threaten it right
away we have bishop to g2 defending the
f3 square and now h6 uh by by karakin
and now how can magnus continue this
game it's not easy to find uh to find
the playable move as black is
controlling a lot of squares probably
you should continue with something very
slow a move like maybe you know h3 or or
something
but magnus goes for f4 uh just attacking
this knight we have knight back to d7
and now knight to a7 as the queen no
longer guards the square now magnus is
threatening queen to c6 to win some
material uh we have queen back to a3
putting pressure on the a4 pawn and now
knight back to c6 attacking the rook
here and where do you where do you put
this rook that's a very interesting
question uh well obviously you could
play rook to c8 which seems very
interesting and even though the queen is
guarding the e7 square uh you're just
not really sure that your queen will
remain on this diagonal for for a very
long time so uh with good reason uh
karjakin plays a rook back to f8 and
you'll see why this is so and now with
rook to f8 he's also kind of offering a
draw he's saying okay if you want you
can capture on d7 and this is a draw if
rook captures we're gonna give up two
knights for a rook here but then we also
play queen captures on e3 with check you
can't go to h1 because you get
checkmated so you have to play king to
f1 and then queen c1 check let's say
king of two and you're gonna pick up the
c4 pawn as well uh it's a rook against
the knight and the bishop where black is
up two pawns so it's very
very unlikely that white will be able to
do anything here uh so like i said that
rook to f8 move kayaking plate is
basically a draw offer so here we have
h3 instead magnus not interested in a
draw and now comes knight to c5 now you
can see that the rook uh here on c8
would wouldn't be very well placed
because now the knight here blocks the
queen's access to d7 square so knight
here would just be very very problematic
so here king to h2 and now comes knight
captures on a4 karakin wins the pawn on
a4
and magnus goes for the attack now we
have rook to d8 and now comes king to g6
giving the king a little bit more
breeding room but the problem is you
also allow carlson to grab hold of this
diagonal so he plays queen to d4 now
with the terrible threat of just
capturing the knight so here we have
king to g7 and now no you cannot capture
the rook king captures and queen
captures uh the knight on f6 because you
forgot that the queen was
still still guarding the rook on f8
uh i know you did don't lie yeah so here
we have uh well a very interesting move
here carlson just plays c5 and it's a
move that seems to be doing a lot
because the queen no longer guards the
rook on a f8 and now you are threatening
something like rook captures king
captures queen captures on f6
and um well you just can't do all that
much if queen captures on c5 you can
play queen captures knight here if
knight captures the queen still isn't
guarding the rook so the same uh plan is
also working but there is one move that
uh magnus completely missed here and
that's exactly what uh karjakin plays
that's the rook captures on d8 and now
what do you play here well there just
isn't a good move uh knight captures on
the e8 but now knight captures on c5 and
now all of a sudden karjakin is up two
pawns and there is not much uh magnus
can do about this magnus finds the
absolute strongest counter play he plays
queen to d6 and now
uh kraken does not find the absolute
best way here the best way is queen a4
you have to give up the b6 spawn and
after you give up the b6 pawn now you
play knight c to d7 attack the queen and
only after the queen moves you're gonna
play queen to a3 and now
you you can continue playing this with
your beautiful pass pawn uh
you know
just marching forward so instead after
queen to d6 karakim played queen to d3
it makes sense he's up to pawn so he
wants to trade queens and it seems like
it's uh you know a similar idea if you
uh capture on b6 you can even start
pushing an a4 right away queen captures
and c5 queen capture 78 and your pass
pawn will be winning however he missed
carlson's idea completely and that is
knight captures an e6 check and now the
problem is you can't capture with the
knight because the queen would hang so
you have to capture with the f pawn uh
and or you could move back king to h7 is
also a move but the knight f8 check and
now you can't go here because the knight
hangs so you have to defend the knight
and we have sort of a repetition here uh
so f captures on e6 was played and now
comes queen to e7 check came to g8 and
queen captures on f6 so magnus still
down in material those two pass pawns
are incredibly scary but he does have a
lot of pressure on these pawns here
however they are defended the knight
defends the e6 pawn and the queen
defends the g6 spawn
uh so kayaking can just start pushing we
have a4 and now we have e4 by magnus uh
now the queen no longer guards the g6
pawn so queen to d7 and now comes queen
captures on g6 with check queen to g7
and queen to e8 check we have queen to
f8 and queen back to c6 uh so still
still playing very very very strongly uh
queen to d8 guarding the b6 pawn the
knight still guards the e6 pawn and
magnus has to continue pushing he plays
f5
we have a3 karjakin wants to bring that
uh pawn all the way all the way to a1 of
course we have f captures on e6 and now
uh king to g7 uh we have e7 attacking
the queen here of course if queen
captures then we're going to pick up the
b6 spawn but there really isn't anything
better because well you can't allow
white to promote this pawn to a queen so
queen captures on e7 queen captures on
b6 attacking now uh the knight uh okay
the knight is defended for the moment
but we go knight to d3
and queen to a5 now
so we're not allowing this pawn to be
pushed anywhere uh we have queen to c5
now offering a queen trade magnus can't
allow this because then the passport
will be too strong impossible to stop so
queen to a6 putting pressure on the
knight here and now knight to e5 and
here uh is the move that really makes a
difference uh but but not for magnus for
for karjakin uh here magnus played queen
to e6 and this simply will not to do
there's a huge huge problem with queen
to e6 you guys of course know what that
is so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find it the only winning move
for karjakin while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on figuring out that
magnus is actually in tutuang and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course h5
this is the the only winning move and
it's incredible uh the problem with
queen being on e6 is that you have no
checks uh you have no checks and you
know if you try to move your queen
somewhere else where you will have some
checks then then it will simply not be
enough for example if you try queen to
a6 now okay you can start giving some
checks it's not enough queen to c3 we're
going to play queen b2 and now our pawn
just becomes a queen and there's no no
sufficient condor play queen b7 check we
can play king h6 and once another check
is given we can even block with knights
the g6 and that's it
queen b2 a2 a1 that's that's that's a
victory even if e5 if you go for some
bishop to e4 ideas it's not enough just
h4 we go after the pawn here and even if
the pawn is captured we can capture on
e5 with the check let's say king g1
queen to a1 would check king to h2 now
a2
again queen to e5 check is coming and
then we just bring another uh
bring another queen into the game so
after this h5 brilliancy by karjakin
there doesn't seem to be a move that
magnus can play h4 was played
but here karjakin just played a2 even
though it seems like the white queen is
guarding that pawn but it was in this
position on move 52 that magnus calls
and resigned the game as there really is
nothing more uh that he can do here uh
to give you an example if the pawn is
captured let's say queen captures an a2
now this hole on the king side knight to
g4 check is just deadly the problem is
if you go king to h1 uh then you just
get checkmated queen to c1 check you
don't have a square you have to play
bishop to f1 and now it's just checkmate
and if you don't after knight to g for
check you can play king to h3 but now
queen g1 threatening queen to h2
checkmate the only move you basically
have is bishop to f3 but now comes
knight to f2 check and you don't have a
move the pawn prevents the king from
going up there also the knight and you
have to give up the queen captures
captures and that's it so
really really an incredible
incredible game where you know a game
could have been drawn many times but uh
both players so wanted that win andy was
magnus who made the final mistake and
allowed karjakin to
uh to
you know just bounce back but it was
interesting that uh karjakin as soon as
he got into winning position he uh
you know he missed why why it was
winning uh here where we mentioned that
uh
this c5 move was played it wasn't a good
move and just rook captures and knight
captures was winning but magnus already
found some deadly counter play with
queen to d6 and karakin failed to find
queen to a4 uh but you know who who
wouldn't knight captures an e6 uh just
seems impossible because the knight also
guards e6 i mean who would who would who
would think that uh but yeah then magnus
bonds back and then uh in the end it was
uh karjakin who was victorious and you
know everyone thought that this would be
the year of karjakin because how could
magnus retaliate but only two runs later
uh magnus uh won one game 10 and then
later on he he won the rapid tie breaks
uh so yeah uh those were the only two
games magnus lost in his world chess
championship matches so the one against
anand in 2014 in uh sochi russia and the
one against sergey karjakin uh in in the
2016 match in new york uh hope you guys
enjoyed that we'll see what happens uh
in the fifth match against nepal like i
said he's a bit of a
more aggressive player he said that
they've prepared something very special
for the match uh so we'll see but uh
like a like i mentioned on twitter uh
the only two games magnus lost in world
chess championship match is playing d4
and playing against d4 so i imagine
nipple will choose for his game one
tomorrow with the white pieces uh the
move one to d4 we'll see if this is so
uh you know but but it would make sense
uh so once again i hope you guys uh
enjoyed that i would like to thank your
give is a good lad uh wish we will find
the boat pito uh henrik fola chatron
club 2000 given mana and dan mccormick
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing uh well or
rather starting the coverage of the
world chess championship ship 2021
between magnus carlsen and ianni ponyshi
thank you all uh and see you soon